أصدر كل من CDC و FDA للتو بيانًا مشتركًا
كنت أقرأه
الآن ويدعو إلى وقف مؤقت فوري
في استخدام
لقاح فيروس كورونا جرعة واحدة من جونسون وجونسون ، وذلك بعد أن أصيب
ستة متلقين في الولايات المتحدة
باضطراب نادر
يشمل  تجلط الدم في غضون
أسبوعين تقريبًا من التحاقنا بالتطعيم
الآن هو الدكتور كارلوس ديل ريو ،
وهو العميد المساعد التنفيذي في
كلية الطب
بجامعة إيموري في نظام الرعاية الصحية هذا أه
هذه الآثار الجانبية الضارة تخثر دم نادر
في
ست نساء حسب الأعمار  ثمانية إلى أربع
18 إلى 48 18 إلى 48 ست نساء
من أصل 6.8 مليون جرعة تم
إعطاؤها دكتور ديل ريو ، لذا ما هو
الوجبات الجاهزة هنا
جيدًا ، شكرًا لك جون أعتقد أن
الوجبات الجاهزة الأولى هي
أنه حدث نادر جدًا ، أعني أنك
تتحدث عن واحدة لكل
مليون وعندما تعطي الملايين من تلك
اللقاحات ، سترى أحداثًا مثل هذه
لا يمكنك رؤيتها في
التجربة السريرية لمجرد أنك تعلم أنه
لم يكن لديك ملايين الأشخاص  مسجل
لذلك من المحتمل أنه مرتبط بأنه نادر الحدوث
ولكن أود أن أهنئ CDC و
FDA على القفز بسرعة كبيرة عليهما
لوقف التطعيمات حتى نعرف
المزيد ونحاول حقًا فهم
ما يحدث وأعتقد أن سلامة اللقاحات
كانت دائمًا
أولوية وأنا  أعتقد أن هذه هي الخطوة الصحيحة تمامًا
حتى نفهم ما يحدث
وما هو السبيل للمضي قدمًا. لدي الكثير
من الأصدقاء الذين حصلوا على هذا اللقاح ،
لذا
أعتقد أن أي شخص حصل في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية يريد أن يعرف ما الذي يجب
البحث عنه هنا  ما تقوله إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير على الأشخاص
الذين حصلوا على هذا
اللقاح في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية والذين
أصيبوا بصداع شديد وألم في البطن أو
ألم في الساق
أو ضيق في التنفس في غضون ثلاثة
أسابيع بعد التطعيم ،
يجب عليهم الاتصال
بمقدم الرعاية الصحية ، وهذا ما يجب عليهم فعله
أه يفعل هذا على الرغم من إظهار  علاقة السببية بالطبيب ،
صحيح ، هذا هو السؤال الكبير ، هل هي
مصادفة أم سببية أم أنهم لا
يعرفون حتى الآن
لا أعتقد أننا نعرف حتى الآن ما
نعرفه ونحتاج إلى فهمه.  أبعد من ذلك ،
لكننا نعلم على سبيل المثال ، أن هناك بيانات
تأتي بشكل
أساسي من أوروبا في لقاح أسترازينيكا
وهو أيضًا
لقاح مضاد للفيروسات ، لذا قد يكون
مرتبطًا بالناقل
الذي قد يكون للقاح الناقل المضاد للفيروسات
علاقة به ،
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة للأشخاص  لا
أضع ذلك في الكلام العادي بالنسبة لنا
جيدًا ، دعني أضعه بعبارات بسيطة جدًا ،
ما يعنيه هو أن أنواعًا معينة من
اللقاحات مثل أستروسينيك وجونسون وجونسون
التي تستخدم
فيروسًا باردًا معطلاً لتوصيل
بروتين التجسس
قد يكون  يؤدي في عدد قليل جدًا من
الأفراد النادرون إلى تطوير الأجسام المضادة ضد
عامل الصفائح الدموية الرابع
الذي يتسبب في
قلة الصفيحات المناعية وتجلط الدم ،
لذا فإن ما يعنيه للناس في هذا
الوقت هو أنه من المحتمل
أن تكون على ما يرام ، أعني أنك تعرف متى
فكر في حدث واحد من كل مليون
تعلم أنك تعبر الشارع
كل يوم لديك فرصة أكبر بكثير
للدهس بسيارة ،
لذا أعتقد أن ما يفعله الناس  يجب أن أكون هو
عدم الخوف ،
سأكون سأكون مستمرًا في حياتي قليلاً ،
لكنني سأكون منسجمًا جدًا مع
جسدي وإذا
أصبت بضيق في التنفس إذا
أصبت بألم في الساق إذا أصبت  صداع وأنا في
غضون أسبوعين إلى ثلاثة أسابيع من تلقي
لقاح جونسون ، سأقوم على الفور
بإخطار مقدم الرعاية الصحية الخاص بي